I was worried about the fact
that physically I am able to
do it in this case
all the references I had
were men
I said to myself
I have thighs that are maybe
half  of their volume
will I manage to descend
a wave there
then I learned little by little
I compensate for being my muscular strength
with my adaptation
it's his complexion intelligence and a lot
of sensitivity also then it  is a
balance also mentally
[Music]
when things are not going well and when I have to
stop and I want
to
language OK
perfect incredible we arrive with all
the luggage
and I wanted to start this season
Ford it was that  there are the first
champagnes in the world at Joyce
I was invited
it's the United
States as a Frenchman and not at the same
level
you really have to make your place and
you don't do it in front of their eyes if they
don't know  realizing it and seeing you
as respecting you as such
[Music]